hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to sing and not to see Carrie
let's talk about the most necessary
movie of 2013 reason to see number one
the finale you're watching an hour and
48 minutes of what I personally thought
was not good stuff to watch but then he
got into the prom finale and I'm not
ruining anything for you guys you guys
have seen the [ __ ] trailers or so I
saw the original well read the book
you're waiting for this finale thing and
then when the fan comes the movie gets
pretty good actually it's like it's
tension-filled it's it's scary and the
effects are finally good early on Roz
like that looks like total CGI right
there that was when they were clear on
what they wanted to do that's what it
seemed like everyone was on the same
page I felt like they said let's just
focus on the finale everything else is
just filler yeah I can kind of get on
with you with that because it seems like
that's the part you think of you think
Oh Carrie pig's blood and then she you
know massacres the school if that's how
they approached it I don't necessarily
agree but I'm glad they at least kind of
stuck that landing
cuz it's thrilling and it's cool to look
at and you know what it is
there's some intense bits in there so
yeah that's some good gore and stuff
reasons not to see the script my biggest
issue with this film yeah definitely the
[ __ ] script to the script is is
pretty shitty one of the weakest parts
about this script is they don't know how
to give proper focus to our main
character the first hour eager with
Carrie she's just like moving [ __ ] the
whole time but they put so much
attention to detail with all the other
stories though sure they all kind of
revolve around Carrie but there's one
more depth to them then that most of the
scenes that feature Carrie alone I don't
necessarily agree with that I mean I do
think [ __ ] I do think the script is
weak but I feel like we got the most
insight into Carrie and her mom and the
rest of it was kind of like okay
the other characters are doing the serve
the plot and the only characters we kind
of get to know it all are Carrie and her
mom you know I realized we just had a
split decision but at the end of the day
it was also a reason not yeah it's like
who is it this is both reasons not but
for different reasons
you know remakes a rampant nowadays
there are tons of them Carrie is a movie
you know that I think you can definitely
remake in a way that's fresh new also
relevant and still stays true to the
spirit of the story and they don't do a
whole lot of that here like it's it's a
remake of Carrie but it's a remake of
Carrie they don't really bring in a
whole lot of new ideas it's sort of like
the Cliff Notes version of Carrie like
they took the best scenes from Carrie
kind of made shorter versions of them
and modernize them you know like let's
give them cellphones and yes there's
cellphones and there's like cyber bully
and that's just a this YouTube uploader
you will never see it yeah and there's
no like emotional fact it's such a lack
of substance with this film it's
weirdest it's like it's all there it's
like in front of you in front of you to
make a damn good trailer for some reason
when you're watching the film it's like
the characters are not fleshed out
properly in a lot of ways my biggest
problem was like the weird imbalance
between there were like three adults at
this school - one of them is completely
oblivious one of them is just an [ __ ]
I guess and then all the kids have
different levels of bullying and then
like the one girl's boyfriend is like
thirty from some other place and their
complies an ex-convict committing crime
and there's a gym teacher who never
leaves the gym gym or locker room yeah
and they're you know bullying seem like
such Hollywood bullying like in the
original Carrie that seemed pretty you
know authentic to me in updating it it
does make sort of things because you can
see how the bullying would work out in
the original film in this film it
doesn't seem like any of this stuff
would fly today by anybody's standards a
guy that's the problem
haven't you seen 21 Jump Street weird is
the new normal and it just doesn't make
any sense why they all hate her you know
I can see why she would be the strange
kid at school but in this movie why are
they going out of their way to be so
awful to her all the time
yeah it's like there's a bully or
every corner is just waiting to be like
carried every split decisions the acting
I want to start off by first saying that
there were moments that I did think that
Chloe grace Moretz did a good job in and
Julianne Moore as well moments I'd say
for Chloe grace Moretz there's like a
good 35 40 percent that I enjoy but
Julianne Moore I like like a solid 40
percent of her performance Morgan yeah
46 earlier did I say 60 yeah I don't
know what I said what I left the theater
I just go with your heart you know calm
for me no 60 we're going 16 is that's a
forty percent of her performance I don't
like though and the other actor is like
God they were you look this movie like
they have like the acting felt like it
was from the first twilight movie nobody
stood out to me and this cast is being
bad like there are certain wobbly flat
moments oh the blonde girl who was like
with a taking sympathy on Carrie I
thought she was pretty bad I thought her
performance was fine like I did these
are great I thought she was okay I
didn't think the script handled her
incredibly well
just cuz there were moments where I'm
like I get that that's what this
character does but I don't get the
motivation based on the scenes you've
given us the main girl picking on Carrie
I thought she was like over-the-top
yeah she's that I'll get with you there
I didn't think she was bad but she
wasn't a different movie I felt like all
that I'm committed to their roles but
they were all in a different movie
except for scenes with Chloe grace
Moretz and Julianne Moore that's one
movie and then the stuff at school is a
different movie that's how I kind of
break this down and Chloe Moretz you
know I was skeptical to begin with I
thought abigail breslin would have been
a better choice if you're going for that
mold and I thought she doesn't know good
fine she's fine
she's definitely okay there are a couple
moments where I was like okay yeah I'm
really into you and then there were a
couple you know there were a bunch of
other moments where I was like yes
you're doing you're doing an okay job I
just don't get why all these people
would pick on such a hot looking girl
she really doesn't look ugly in this
film at first I was like oh they did a
good job with her hair I could see why
people might put big check on her but as
the film's going it's like this crew
is just beautiful to look at you know I
can even forgive that I can be like okay
given her upbringing and her just her
social vibe I can see how maybe she
would still be weird awkward socially
introverted person but I thought she was
playing all those like things yeah no I
can see that is it I didn't feel like
she was being those things yeah she was
only intermittently like in the quad
gave me no rub my shoulders and look
like this she was like a better-looking
version at Kristen Stewart I that's a
very very harsh criticism I think she
does a better job than Kristen Stewart
doesn't a better acting version of
Kristen Stewart sure
as far as Julianne Moore goes there were
times where I was laughing and I don't
blame that on her actually I think
Julianne Moore was really committed to
the film she thought she was in I just
felt that the way they captured it felt
like she was in a completely different
type of Johor John just on a technical
level she is because her scenes are only
with Carrie and they're only in the
house except for the one like she was on
set she was only in that movie the poem
that would the character for me it might
be the writing itself maybe not her
performance she was she seemed very
laughable to me I thought the the guy
who took her - from and stuff was
charming in her memory it was great yeah
I liked him a lot him in prison guy they
were awesome to me so what decision
number two directing actually my biggest
issue with this was the directing to me
not the script the directing I felt had
way too many tonal shifts they would go
back and forth between horror teen drama
horror teen drama but it was like
different variations of horror at
different variations of teen drama it
just didn't have a consistent tone every
scene just felt like a different movie
all the sudden a lot like the first
Twilight movie I agree with you there no
I'm right you're wrong about your
feelings I don't know I don't think
every scene feels like a different movie
I can get on board with you in the sense
that this stuff that takes place in
Carrie and her mom's house does feel a
bit different from the stuff that takes
place everywhere else high school drama
it's you know telekinetic horror movie
they go together cuz if you remember the
original that's a very weird movie in
terms of tone shift because they'll have
like the stuff going on at home and then
there's like a sped-up like with crazy
music and there
and for you know clothes for the prom
and then they'll do like all the high
school scenes in that movie are weird
too but that's what I mean they're
trying to replicate Carrie but I don't
feel that it's executed in a way work
I'm just going on if its own merits when
I was watching I wasn't comparing and I
don't think that way that it was
distracting to me it wasn't enjoyable
but I think Kimberly Peirce's talented
like I know she she knows how to capture
this stuff I think it looks good Rosetta
I thought it was lazy directing I
thought I only looked good when Mike
come in the finale no I liked her camera
movement I like you know where I was so
lazy there was something really there's
some really cool shots I thought she had
a consistent visual style throughout
Jerry you don't know what you're talking
about
Ryan's Consensus a lazy shitty movie is
the reason not to see Carrie 2013 a lazy
shitty movie is the reason not to see
Carrie 2013 if they showed Chloe grace
Moretz movies that would have blown my
mind yeah Jerry's Consensus a passable
remake of Carrie is the reason to see
Carrie if you want a passable remake of
Carrie is the reason to see Carrie if
you want yeah you know like I said I
liked some of it other stuff I was kind
of whatever about it's okay alright guys
thanks for checking out a review for
Carrie why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below and tell me what
did you think of Chloe grace Moretz and
then once you're done with that come
over here and click this button so you
can see more of a sense of reasons to
see can you do us a favor and follow us
on Twitter cuz we'll follow you back and
it'd be nice to you know just to
communicate with some fans out there you
know really really get to know the tens
of you and once you're done with
following us on Twitter we're really
making you do a lot I know like us on
Facebook and then once you're done with
all that stuff if you're interested in
getting updated perhaps when a new
review or video is out then you're gonna
want to subscribe watch I'm gonna move
that that mouse for you she's neo from
the matrix that's what I was thinking of
when she was like doing stuff to her mom
dad oh yeah that's not the new girl
a be cool of carry was like part of the
adventures that would be really twisted
if you did it the right way but yeah
well I'm sure they could do some like
time-travel thing where before the prom
and then they recruit her to here it
comes
yeah Nick Fury comes
[Music]